Movies: they're everywhere.
With multiple new releases coming out every
single day, there's just no way anybody has
the time or money to see all of them.
Which is too bad, because it means that a
lot of really good films go completely under
the radar.
Heck, you may not have even heard of some
of the best films of the year!
Don't worry, though, because we've got your
back.
Here's a look at some of the brilliant movies
of 2017 you totally missed.
Prevenge
Ask anyone who's ever been pregnant, and they'll
tell you that the whole "creating another
human with your own body" thing isn't easy.
Back pain, swollen feet, and a rollercoaster
of emotions are enough to make even the most
calm people go a little crazy.
But in Prevenge, that pregnancy-induced madness
quickly turns... to murder.
Writer/director Alice Lowe plays Ruth, a pregnant
woman grappling with the death of her partner.
As her due date nears, Ruth begins listening
to the menacing supernatural thoughts of her
unborn child, and starts to believe the world
should be held accountable for ultimately
leaving her baby without a father.
Cue a revenge-fueled killing spree that leads
Ruth to reevaluate each piece of her wildly
fragmented life.
"Just so that you know you have absolutely
no control over your mind or your body anymore.
This one does."
Oh, and that's no prosthetic belly there:
Lowe was actually in her third trimester when
she filmed Prevenge.
Talk about Method acting!
Chuck
Once upon a time there was a regular guy named
Chuck Wepner who sold liquor and did some
prizefighting on the side for cash to support
his family.
Then, one day in 1975, he was cherry-picked
from a sea of boxers to go glove-to-glove
with one of the world's greatest athletes:
boxing legend Muhammad Ali.
As most film fans know, Wepner's amazing story
famously inspired the classic film Rocky.
'How can I help you Mr. Wepner?"
"You follow boxing?"
"Rocky?"
"Tell Sly, Rocky's here."
"I can handle this."
But unlike the fictionalized Rocky, Chuck
aims to tell the true tale of this unlikely
sports hero, with Liev Schreiber in the lead
and a great cast including Naomi Watts backing
him up.
The Lost City of Z
Charlie Hunnam, Robert Pattinson, Sienna Miller,
and the new Spider-Man himself Tom Holland
teamed up for The Lost City of Z, a thought
provoking adventure tale about a group of
explorers searching the Amazon for a legendary
lost civilization.
"I call it Zed.
The ultimate piece of the human puzzle!"
Unfortunately, The Lost City of Z opened the
same weekend as The Fate of the Furious, so
pretty much nobody had any idea it existed,
and it vanished from the box office almost
instantly.
The good news?
That gives you the opportunity to unearth
a cinematic lost treasure of your own.
The Transfiguration
This one is definitely not your average vampire
thriller.
The Transfiguration shifts its focus away
from classic vampire tales to the story a
young teen named Milo who shields himself
from the unfriendly outside world with a deep-rooted
fascination with the undead.
But that interest turns lethally obsessive
when he becomes friends with the troubled
Sophie, leading to a chilling slice-of-afterlife
indie horror flick that will leave you completely
transfixed.
"And you change a lot, after the first person
you kill.
You change a lot more after… after one after
another?"
The Devil's Candy
Ethan Embry stars in this sinfully delicious
horror film about a tortured artist who blacks
out and wakes to discover he has painted a
horrifying portrait of pure evil.
Has he been touched by some kind of holy - or
unholy - force?
Or is he simply going mad?
The only way to find out is to watch The Devil's
Candy for yourself.
If you dare!
T2 Trainspotting
To anyone who's said sequels rarely stack
up, we counter with T2 Trainspotting, the
21-years-later follow-up to Danny Boyle's
classic Trainspotting.
Two decades on, T2 peeks in on the life of
the gang from the original, with Begbie, Renton,
Spud and Sick Boy each in an unexpected - or
all too expected - place in their lives.
Can people really change?
Or is that just an illusion we sell ourselves?
Boyle's inventive sequel asks the questions,
but you may not like the answers.
"Where did it all go wrong?
Hahaha."
"Where did it all go wrong?"
I Don't Feel at Home in This World Anymore
This Netflix exclusive release stars Elijah
Wood and Melanie Lynskey as a pair of eccentric
neighbors who embark on a quest to track down
the thieves who burgled her home.
Their mission quickly melts into chaos and
violence as they frantically try to outwit
the pack of corrupt criminals following their
every move.
I Don't Feel at Home in This World Anymore
bursts forward with an inventive, subversive,
slyly smart, and downright fun feel that'll
have you hollering in one scene and pondering
society's structure in the next.
"All right tough guy, you had your chance."
"Ow ow."
"Oh God… are you OK?"
Dig Two Graves
The brainchild of screenwriters Hunter Adams
and Jeremy Phillips, the indie horror outing
Dig Two Graves centers around 14-year-old
Jacqueline Mather, referred to by her more
masculine nickname "Jake."
Grieving for her recently deceased brother,
Jake is thrown for a loop when she's visited
by three strange men who say they can bring
him back to life.
"I'm not supposed to talk to strangers, so..
I'm Wyeth.
Now that we know each other we're no longer
strangers."
Are they telling the truth?
What lengths will Jake have to go to see her
brother again?
And what does her grandfather, Sheriff Waterhouse,
have to do with it?
As Jake begins to contemplate an unthinkable
trade-off, dark secrets of her family's once-hidden
history rises to the surface.
Inspired by gothic motifs of grief and revenge,
and soaked with the uncertainty of an ambiguous
timeline, Dig Two Graves should captivate
discerning genre enthusiasts.
And though it didn't make any big waves at
the box office, given its tiny release, Dig
Two Graves has been showered with acclaim
from critics, with RogerEbert.com calling
it an "uncommonly smart, well-made, and ultimately
touching meditation on grief."
Colossal
You'd expect a film with a title like Colossal
to be an overhyped summer tentpole, but this
pitch black sci-fi indie comedy came and went
without getting the media attention it deserved.
Colossal stars Oscar-winning actress Anne
Hathaway as Gloria, a woman in the throes
of a post-breakup existential limbo who's
shocked to realize she actually has bigger
problems than just curbing her drinking and
getting back on the dating scene.
Like, giant reptilian kaiju-sized problems
in the form of an enormous monster terrorizing
South Korea.
These two things don't sound like they could
possibly be part of the same movie, but the
way Colossal connects them is just part of
the film's genius.
"I just feel like dancing so ah… so guess
which film this from huh?
"F--- is going on?"
"Do you want to make any requests?
This does not last that long."
A distinctly unique take on the monster movie
genre boasting ultra fresh performances from
Hathaway and Jason Sudeikis, Colossal is decidedly
strange in the very best way.
From the Seoul street fights reminiscent of
Rock 'em Sock 'em Robots to the ultimate narrative
twist, here's a film weird and wild enough
to stretch your definition of what a creature
feature should be.
Raw
This foreign horror flick is just as formidable
in English as it is in French.
Raw, which was called Grave in its original
European release, starts off so simply it
may even elicit laughter.
A movie all about a vegetarian adjusting to
college life amongst meat-eating peers?
Not exactly captivating.
But writer-director Julia Ducournau practically
slaps you across the face with a rack of raw
ribs in the moments that follow.
Happy-go-lucky freshman and lifelong plant-eater
Justine has high hopes for veterinary school
and intends to be laser-focused on her studies.
However, her mind soon shifts to a different,
unexpected target: human flesh, the taste
she acquires after she's forced to eat raw
meat during a hazing ritual.
As Justine tries to make sense of her newfound
cannibalistic desires, Raw swerves down the
winding road of navigating college parties,
uppity professors, and the complexities of
sexual identity.
We won't spoil the ending, but we have a feeling
that Raw's third act is what catapulted it
into the laps of many adoring critics—and
made a few viewers fall out of their seats.
Bloody and brutal but oh-so bright, Raw is
a film you can really sink your teeth into.
Literally.
Land of Mine
After making big waves at the Toronto International
Film Festival and in Danish theaters in 2015,
Land of Mine finally hit theaters in America
at the beginning of 2017, not that anyone
seemed to notice.
That's a shame considering how gripping Land
of Mine is.
Based on a true story, the film is set in
Denmark at the end of 1945.
Freed from German occupation, the country
was still filled with thousands of hidden
land mines.
Sgt.
Carl Rasmussen and his band of German prisoners
of war are tasked with clearing the explosives,
a job that brings into question justice, morality,
and vengeance in a single breath.
"(speaking Dutch)"
This historical drama earned itself a 2017
Oscar nomination for Best Foreign Language
Film, a standing ovation at TIFF, and the
title of best Danish film of 2015.
If Land of Mine is missing from your watchlist,
change that immediately—if not sooner.
The Salesman
A twisty and intriguing drama from Iran, The
Salesman tells the story of Emad and Rana,
a theater loving couple who set out to stage
a production of Arthur Miller's classic play
Death of a Salesman.
After Rana is attacked, however, their lives
are upended as the need for revenge begins
to take center stage in their lives.
"(Speaking Farsi)"
Lauded as an "ingenious cinematic use" of
the American stage, The Salesman's story-within-a-story
brings to light questions about violence against
women, marriage, post-traumatic stress, death,
and the class system, and asks the audience
to work through them as the film runs on.
Though The Salesman might've slipped past
you, it certainly wasn't lost with critics,
landing itself the Oscar for Best Foreign
Language Film at the 89th Academy Awards.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!